-This is a fantastic show.
I'm enjoying it so much.
-I was very familiar with th
"Watchmen" comic book.
You were less so.
-I wasn't at all.
So you're way ahead of me.
-Yeah.
But Laurie Blake -- this is
very kick-ass character to play.
Have you enjoyed it so far
-Oh, my God. I had a ball.
Yeah.
-I mean, I can only imagine.
I should note that
in the comics,
which took place in the '80s
Laurie Blake's character
you played
wore a lot of spandex.
Now you're an FBI agent.
-That was -- Yeah.
-Yeah. Are you happy --
-That was one of my
first questions is,
"Don't make me wear
that outfit."
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And it seems like the
FBI outfit seems very fitting.
-The basic black, yeah.
-Basic black.
Your son knew the comic book
Is he excited --
-No, he didn't, but he's ver
psyched about the show.
He loves the show.
-Okay. That's good.
-So I'm still the cool mom
-Oh, that's good.
-Hanging in there.
-Just hanging in there
on the cool-mom thing.
-Yeah.
-The wonderful actor --
you could not tell behind his --
shiny silver mask -- is
Tim Blake Nelson.
-Mirror guy!
-Mirror guy, Tim Blake Nelson.
How is it working --
It's a fantastic cast
from top to bottom,
but how was Tim?
-He's a new buddy.
I just love him.
First of all, he's one of
the smartest people
I have ever met in my life
He's a real intellect.
And also a minx.
He's always saying, you know
naughty things
to make you laugh.
-Gotcha.
-But he's a very dangerous
person, actually,
to be on the road with.
-Okay. How so?
-Well, he invited me to a
strip club in Atlanta.
-Okay.
-Where we were shooting.
It's called the Clermont Lounge.
You can Google it.
It's C-L-E-R-M-O-N-T.
-Okay.
-And it's become famous becaus
all of the strippers
are in their 60s and 70s.
-Is this a true thing?
-This is a true thing.
And I don't mean to
mock those ladies,
but it's not like they're,
like, ex-dancer.
This is, like, your grandma...
-Really?
-...going out there and just
pulling her top down
and going...
-Wow! So this --
-It's not to be believed,
and he just decided
that we had to experience
this together for some reason.
And, so, we sat there.
And, first of all, I should have
known not to go in,
because I was meeting him there,
and when I went to the door --
it's in a basement of a hotel --
to get my wrist stamped
and I bought my ticket, the gu
who was stamping my wrist
didn't even move his cigarette
and he burned me.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, and I should have jus
turned around and gone right -
-Yeah. That's a very -- That's a
red flag of all red flags,
if the guy in charge of security
is burning the customers.
-Exactly. And, so, you know,
we watched the ladies
and we tipped them.
-Oh, that's very nice of you
-Yeah, and one of them, when
she wasn't dancing,
came over and asked me if
I wanted to dance.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was like,
"Um, well, oh, gosh.
No, thanks.
No, but thank you very much.
And I realized
she wasn't saying,
"Do you want to dance?"
She was saying
"Do you want a dance?"
-Oh, my God.
-And I looked around.
I went, "Oh, lap dances.
-So even these women at this age
are even doing lap dances?
-Yes, they were offering m
a lap dance.
-And is this, like --
-She was a little bit younger.
She was maybe 50.
-Yeah.
So in the prime of her
stripping years, yeah.
-Yes. Yes.
No, it was not to be believed.
And then, you know, a guy --
A giant drunk guy
knocked me off my barstool
-Yeah. It seems like hanging out
with Tim Blake Nelson,
intellect or not,
doesn't seem like
a very safe thing to do.
-No. He text me the next day
and goes, "How are you?
That was great.
We were chasing life."
And it was like -- But I have to
say, he is a very nice man
He's very happily married.
-Yeah.
-And he's a very good daddy.
So, Tim, don't be mad.
-I feel like I don't -- I don'
feel like we'll remember
any of those other details
You have a couple interestin
props in this show.
The first one I'm gonna talk
about is, you have a pet owl
-Yes.
-And you had to --
In one of the episodes,
you fed the pet owl
a live mouse.
-Yes.
-Were you holding a live mouse
-Yes, I was.
I said, "I can't feed him
to the owl.
I can't do that.
I don't mind holding
a mouse, but no."
And they said, "Oh, no, no
We'll cut to the owl later."
The owl was close up.
But the mouse -- the poor
mouse -- every time --
'Cause they wanted it hangin
down, dangling.
He kept crawling up on top
of my hand like --
-Sure. 'Cause he doesn't kno
it's not real.
-Wouldn't you?
-You're like, "No, no, mouse
This is a movie. This is TV.
-"Help me!"
So, we had to do several takes
until he finally
just sort of --
-Gotcha. You just tire him out
It's like working with kids.
You just do it enough
until they're too tired.
The other thing -- You know,
I'm trying to think of
the classiest way to say it,
but one of your props
in the show is
a giant blue dildo.
-You're really going to go
there, aren't you?
-I mean, what else
are you gonna call it?
I feel like -- Now,
when they first told you -
When this was first introduced
to you as a --
And I will say,
the shocking thing is,
reading the comic book, I
immediately got what this was.
-Yes.
-But not being a comic fan
were you taken aback
when you realized this was -
-Well, yes, because they sen
me the script
after they offered me the part
And I'm reading.
I'm thinking, "This is so great.
This is cool.
Now she's got -- What's she --
Oh, dear God, no."
Now, I mean, it's the only tim
I've been sort of
grateful that my parents
are no longer with us.
-Oh, that's --
-It's like...
-It's nice, though.
-Just for that minute.
-Just for one minute.
-I miss them so much.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, no, that --
I think I would have had to --
-Yeah. Well, I think the goo
thing to know is --
if they were with you --
still with us,
that would have killed them.
-Well...
-Yeah.
So it's probably for the best.
Now it's not on you.
[ Laughter ]
-No, actually, my mother could
have dealt with it.
My father, no.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, that makes sense.
That makes sense.
I know this show is
very much under wraps.
I believe four of the nine
have aired
at this point of this interview.
-Yeah.
-You probably can't give
anything away.
Is there anything you want t
tell us to look for
while we're watching it
or are you just too under wraps?
-Oh, gosh.
No. I just think that
something that your people
are hoping for,
they'll probably --
might get to see, and somethin
that they didn't expect at all
they're gonna see, and they're
almost the same thing.
-That is fantastically vague
and somehow --
somehow makes me want to
watch it even more.
And I already wanted to
watch a lot.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Jean Smart, everybody.